hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast achieving higher resolution
protein impurity analysis with
microfluidic capillary electrophoresis I
am Judy O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by lab roots comm
the leading social media site for
science professionals and sponsored by
PerkinElmer PerkinElmer is a global
leader focused on improving the health
and safety people and the environment
their innovative detection imaging
informatics and service capabilities
combined with deep market knowledge and
expertise help customers gain greater
insights into their science before we
start there are a few instructions this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button at the bottom left corner and
follow the process to receive your
credits we want to hear from you during
this interactive broadcast so please ask
questions or leave us a comment
answers are welcome to and you can do
this by hitting the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if we don't
have time today want a better look you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button on the top right or use
the Q&A button we'll make sure we try to
resolve any issues now let's get right
to today's presenters we are proud to
welcome James white PhD and on a Bob
Fosse PhD dr. white is a senior
application scientist in the Applied
genomics Diagnostics division at
PerkinElmer his research and development
is focused on new product innovations
for the PerkinElmer lab chip is a
portfolio and affords new DNA and
protein microfluidic capillary
electrophoresis applications James's
research experience spans chemistry
polymer chemistry and biomedical
engineering
prior to joining PerkinElmer James was a
postdoctoral fellow at Tufts University
where he applied his chemistry
background towards the development and
analytical characterization of
neurological tissue scaffolds dr.
Tripathi leads a research group at
University that develops new pathogen
diagnostic platforms by integrating
biological and engineering principles
this work has a broad impact on
scientists engineers physicians and
entrepreneurs
he holds many patents has over 100
peer-reviewed publications and has
delivered more than 50 invited talks
dr. chapati is a fellow of the american
institute of medical and biological
engineering prior to brown he led the
development of micro fluidics chips for
protein and DNA sizing at caliper life
sciences now PerkinElmer this technology
is sold in more than 1 million ships a
year the speakers complete BIOS are
found on the lab routes website I will
now turn it over to dr. to poppy for his
presentation hi everybody this is Anna
pasta party I'm gonna in next 20 minutes
I'm gonna tell about some fundamental
behind my cathodic CAE or microfluidic
capillary electrophoresis and how we can
use that for high resolution protein
impurity and all this is so then I take
you to the next slide as overview of
micro cool effect electrophoresis we
deal with four aspects of it instrument
kids chips and software here the
instrument is provided by which is
developed by programmer the chip and the
case which has all the components which
we use in there in a micropedic chip is
provided by cage and then microphone a
chip which is with Alcala more about it
and go deep the ion that is the engine
for this multiple electrophoresis and of
course everything is controlled by a
quantitative software which I'll tell
you about it we can use this piece for
components to perform many microphone
excesses but I would like to focus on
proteins today where we graph emphasize
how it is geared towards
protein electrophoresis in a better way
so I'll go to the next slide so first
about
what are these micropedic chips so as we
have known and this technology has
matured especially led by Orkin hammer
where chips are manufactured on glass or
quartz wafer and this is very important
because last properties and quartz
properties are well-known among
biologists and it's used by all
Dietetics world
the second is caddy where you can unload
the reagents well and that is also
important because you would like to use
reagents of as you volume at the volume
you would like to use which is up to 30
microliter ad micrometers or more then
it's a sipper which is also an important
aspect of it that it sits or it goes a
secular ticker is a capillary that goes
into your 96 384 well plate where you
have your samples all what we do is we
take communicate with your sample using
fluid and analytical at actuation by
electro kinetics or pressure or vacuum
flow the samples are detected by a laser
induced fluorescence and we have
excitation in this instrument is about
635 nanometer and emission is 700
nanometer chip also have the RFID tags
it basically guides us that how many
samples the chip has been used and when
it's the expiration date this is this
comes with the with their knowledge of
that how long the chips Club can a lot
you know in a long run and that means
very very long run as you see in the
diagram table the channel file
isoparametric tells and there are two
junctions shown that the junctions of
the channel these are very repeatable
process and polymer is actually
worldwide known for making these very
precise directed microchip not only for
PerkinElmer but for other vendors like
Agilent Technologies let's go to the
next slide here I would like to tell
overall layout of the chair so we
exactly understand what is happening in
this essay so we can actually
rationalize our results based on the
chip layout and chip
others so first thing I want to say is
that chip has many wells
as you can see the reservoir some are
green color some are not color in
general red color and they are connected
while it's handled and I'll go a little
bit deeper on that so we can on the chip
lowered marker well which is where we
have the marker which is a lower marker
which is often a dye which basically
tells us that with respect to die all
related Peaks then we have some well
where we put gel which is nothing but P
DNA or polymer gel and with along with
at PS and die and then we have a like
universe where we apply a pressure to
step up the sample as you can see there
is a zipper attached to every chip which
we get and I'm showing the zipper with
an iron were here and then we have
actually two channels which are distinct
Channel and Jim and I will quote go into
that move it so what is the unique thing
about this microchip which is really
unique to actually this product is that
the chip can function in a
high-throughput way that means that it
zipper can take as many samples with one
and do the electrophoresis
that's one so we don't need many many 96
capillaries only single injection does a
single chip can take many many 90s
examples the second is automation that
all electric field and pressure is
automated it's all software driven so we
even the loading of the gel is automated
so the user I just have to click a
button and and all the script basically
runs the micro click ship and cheaply
reused and which is very important
aspect with you the chips can go many
many plays and because it's glass wafer
we understand God very well
block can be cleaned with variety
samples keep the tip large very very
long so let's go to next slide where I
deep dive into the first step first step
is always injection of a sample or a
ladder or a standard so as you can see
that there
red channel showing the fluid flow and
in this what happens that we apply a
pressure in in a well which I'm showing
with the arrow vacuum pressure and it
brings the sample to the channel which
is showing it has the marker to the
visit sample and it starts playing this
process takes only few seconds to do
that what happens that we bring the
sample sample to the to the microphone
escape and it it it is ready to be
loaded into the gels part of the chip
which is the next step the
state-of-the-art is that we only need
now lead your sample to analyze and when
we go to the next sample is cleans of
the previous sample and then we inject
that so let's go to the next slide in
the next slide we do cross injection
that means we apply electric field
between the wealth which I show you are
oh there we apply a negative electrode
and in the second well where we apply a
positive electrode and if you do that
the sample which is sitting in this
portion of the chip injects into the
other part of the chip because mostly
proteins are negatively charged and they
go towards the positively charged and
they go to a cross junction which is
shown by a circle of black circle over
there and that's what we are driving it
and this process is very actually
happens only for two seconds or so to
move the sample into the cross-sectional
area this is very very important because
here we can size the roughly 30 to 40
micron so you can make 30 to 40 micron
of plug or or width of the sample which
is a state-of-the-art for this chip
because any other techniques you have to
submit as a pressure or using
capillaries and the plug sides are very
very long and that has a huge actually
advantage of these chips that since
black sides are small you can do
separation also very very quick so
that's leads to the second chip where we
want to actually separate so here if you
see
the channel I'm going to show you the
challenges operation channel which is
over here where the plug which we
indicated which we have in the junction
it goes towards this operation channel
what we did in this class is we apply
actually the positive electrode here and
the negative electrode over this well
and the sample a goes to the T power
positive electrode in this process this
plugs which we have the 30 micron plug
is now having all the proteins are
fragment and they start separating going
towards the detection point as shown in
a chip so since the del has has the
usual characteristics of concentration
and molecular weight and they're
optimized for high resolution separation
of these proteins so these proteins are
separated by the time they reach these
channels are not that long enough this
is the microphone except you are not
like very long capillaries and the
separation happens in in the time limits
of 1062 140 seconds and you will see
later on result other competing
technologies where we have to wait for
10 minutes and all that and the reason
behind which is very important to know
and often missed by by most of the
scientific community is that the plug
size which which is only 30 micron if we
have a very high sensitive detection we
can separate very quickly longest
websites will take longer time to do
that even the sensitivity can go up that
is the very very important aspect of
this of this microphone a chip there's
one more aspect because we have some
background coming because we do as DF
page or SDS gel electrophoresis and ICS
often grab this hydrophobic dye which we
use to decorate this protein so let's go
to the next slide to understand this
better so what is happening is that just
before detection here here you see in
the slide actually the on the left side
the whole microchip drawn redrawn again
and you see this stain Channel okay
which is which are coming from well
number two
and well number nine as I'm showing
through this through my arrows so what
happens during separation we apply a
crank from the number two and Willow
nine going towards well number ten which
is shown over here with my arrow so as
protein is passing through the
separation channel which is shown over
here it's going up then before just
before the detection as you see in a
detection window they get diluted so to
speak or D stained up before detection
so what happens is that since there is
no as the earth in well number two and
nine their only ionic flow which makes
at the earth concentrations go down
abruptly so as you can see down usual
eyes this if you see the picture down on
the left corner and I'm showing where
the arrow you can imagine the whole
protein and SDS complex is moving and
it's getting diluted what happened that
when XTS concentration as they say
sodium dodecyl sulfate which is a
perfect end it makes vitals and if you
decrease the concentration below a
certain critical micellar concentration
which is the property thermodynamic
property of this SDS then it breaks into
monomers like small pieces so time to
read this as SDS micelle from when we
dilute is about one hundred eighty
eighty eight or two hundred milliseconds
and that is very very fast so that what
happens is that protein bound to my toes
which are stronger obviously because
protein has more hydrophobic domains
those might will stay on and they died
is still forests where the background
fluorescence goes down abruptly now this
is shown in our experiments on that on
that figure which is on the right corner
so when you have no at this game which
is shown the curve which I'm going to
show an arrow over here you'll hardly
see any pigs because background is very
very high as you see is one hundred but
as you keep applying more and more
dilute the stain current or these tend
ratio becomes a high
which is shown by dr you see that at
this pain ratio of 14 you start seeing
Peaks a very high level P so that is
actually the the innovation and key
innovation in this in this chip that you
can dynamically actually create D stain
of the protein think there is no
membrane and washing and manual washing
this is all automated so that's very
very good we can see the peaks and you
can move move towards resolving these
proteins so let's go to the next slide
so what happens is that for for lots of
other customers in almost now only
customers need actually very repeatable
results whether they do the experiments
today or tomorrow or use our for chip or
or the large chip or or different users
and as we understand that that different
users may have very small amount of
error in their pipetting or from the
refrigerator at the lab and exercise
they may incur some small errors and we
are talking about really really small
error even though we are doing using
very very accurate poverty but even if
you use very very small errors there are
some variability is going to come
because our concentration or signal are
dependent on this variable so what we
have done is we found that we can
achieve actually a smart marketing
separations by putting a feedback
algorithm and this is called integer
feedback technology which polymerize
develop so what happens is that we can
eliminate any perturbation which are
going to be very small the end of time
but we have to eliminate that by finding
out the solution for that so there are
two approaches we have taken this out we
have taken in this intelligent feedback
to body first is that if there is any
which are not going to be is there any
changes in conductivity of the gel when
we apply current
that or the concentration of gel let's
say your language L which is the polymer
and if there is small perturbation in
concentration there we basically tip a
ladder and through this dip ladder it
understands it calculates all the
voltage current equations again and then
apply the whole those voltage
concentration currently values to these
wells or these reservoirs which get
leads to the migration times the latter
Peaks to be the same what it helps is
that if I am doing the experiment or if
some other person is doing the
experiment and we have little errors in
the concentration of the gel or
conductivity it leads to the trend
voltage applied to this and lead to the
same arrival time that is very good this
is how the tip we standardized it first
true of a voltage current the equations
the second part is as for Bioethics we
know that there will be a there will be
if there is a small change in the
concentration of s therefore die we
would like to correct that - I'll
correct that - and that we and you're
talking about femtomolar variability so
we have we are going to a very very high
equator I say here so when we take two
maps which is molecule antibody and we
ask a question that we would like the
ratio of it which is a standard to be
the same then we basically take use the
standard and then ensure that that the
map to STS and map to die ratios remain
constant and this we achieve by the
distance which we talked about in the
last life so when this thing ratio is
fixed to keep make sure that the map as
the earth map to die ratio same our trip
is really standardized now for every
customer
ready to go for their sample after that
there is no change all the chip
conditions are fixed and we go for that
so this is how we basically make sure
that intelligent technology may give us
little high-resolution are criticizing
and purity and this is all we want to
achieve it within sixty to one forty
seconds to do that so let me illustrate
two points as you would understand what
is what what if we take a standard from
from a from a customer before going dad
let me show you a real data which we we
are trying to talk about so you see a a
plot here where we are plotting the real
data we are we changing actually the
destain ratio and asking a question that
you have this value map standard which
is a a big thick which is that one and a
small peak which is mapped to and we
would like to basically see the effect
of these pain ratio as we are we are
changing the news generation and syria
secondly speak ratio so the question in
our hand is because we are providing
this or PerkinElmer is providing this a
very map which is the exact ratio which
we are doing it we can actually achieve
that in different chip loads of
different region or different cuts
different users and ask a question that
what these ten ratio i run to get the
same purity which we expect because
those are the molecules those are the
percentage of molecules yes put in the
example so as you can see that once we
read this the software automatically
measures this before you when we go to
the samples in the warming face and it
plot this curve which is what is the
disdain ratio and what is the
corresponding purity and if you see that
this purity is going down as this
generation and this is the this is the
effect basically happening because we
are changing the the map to SDS and map
to dilation as you can see that the chip
optimized itself to the purity which is
10 percent and reads of leaders
generation once you reach stop this
restrain ratio it fix it for the optimal
as optimal restrain ratio for the known
standard which is supplied by britain
hammer and then we ready to go to do
that so let's do some experiment
so the first experiment obviously you
would think that we should do something
which is available as a standard and
what we found that NIST is providing
malasana antibodies called next map list
map and which is indexed reverse
reference material eight six seven one
and you can buy it the good thing about
is that it is a recombinant humanized
igg1 k well characterized females with
the published data with molecule weight
150 kilo dalton and start concentration
of 10 milligram per ml so what we did is
that we got this material and we thought
that let's run it in the both the
devices which we would which we have one
is using ABC IX p 800 which is shown on
left and microphonic internet chip
technology which is GX touch on in the
right so the two points I would like to
highlight these are non reduce miss map
so you see that the baseline is very
constant for this intelligent feedback
technology however in and the left side
D the wave line baselines wave baby also
I would like to show that all these
peptides are coming like light chain
heavy chain likely and heavy chain and
heavy chain light chain as you can see
they are much they are much better it's
all in microfluidic technology I just
want to highlight that left side the
migration kinds of the order of 24 to 30
minutes the left side migration types of
30 seconds so we are having order of
magnitude advantage when you take you to
the other slide the next slide where we
are trying to emphasize on reduce the
thing where we want to quantify things
as you can see that we on the left side
again ABC X data and right side right
comparison of the same pathology of the
G extra data as you can see that we can
resolve all the kicks very well by brute
technology however lab tip technology
takes much shorter time also very
repeatable between users as well as as
between the chips so this to summarize
the these results I would like to say
that we found independently that
intelligible
which is identified all 30 segments a
robust measurement a high lyrical
digital data which is very important
because for each customer like me would
like to see digital tip to check with
through meant to instrument or who is
doing it to be the same and that's the
most important part of this until
internship electrophoresis we also would
like to emphasize that p800 it takes 20
to 30 minutes for samples and markup or
it takes only 60 seconds per sample and
we would like to say that we can bracket
most of the antibody researcher by
through critical research using this
microphone except with that I would take
the last slide that this software is
very very powerful here
and I don't want to emphasize these
things are done by many companies that
we can quantify those percentage purity
in all that is automated and there is no
manual work which we have to do even by
taking the peaks or counting the peaks
are calculating the area of the
calculating percent percentage purity is
all done automatically by the software
to spit out results in any format you
would like with that I would like to
give the presentation to my colleague
dr. white to take it from there and tell
more about the applications of this
Thank You Annabelle the goal of my part
of the second part of the presentation
will be to describe the protein assay
portfolio and really talk about how we
use the technology platform that Anna
Bob described to to attack and enable
you to solve your protein
characterization applications that are
necessary for your lab I'll also
emphasize some more data and talk about
our new protein clear assay and new
developments there and I'll also talk
about the workflow for the protein clear
assay and how you are able to use this
in your laboratory so the lab chip GX
two-touch platform as on a bob said is a
very powerful analytical tool for
microfluidic electro phoretic separation
of proteins
and we're also able to use this
technology for separation of DNA as well
but today we'll be focusing on the
protein space and is able to
characterize proteins looking for for
many different critical quality
attributes some of these attributes
include tighter so you can look at
concentration and sizing we focus a lot
on purity assessment and our protein
clear assay is really targeted at
looking at the percent purity of maps we
can also look at for aggregation
covalently linked aggregates it can be
stability indicated so very useful for
degradation studies and mab and bio
therapeutic development and looking at
fragmentation analysis we can look at
and glycan profiling profiling as well
and look at charge heterogeneity so map
charge variant SI and then also if
you're looking for purity assessment
there's purity assessment of your main
Peaks but then also really looking at
the fine details of the impurity
analysis so the ability to detect minor
impurities of your samples is very
important though our workflows are
developed to work using reducing and non
reducing conditions and we have multiple
assays for protein characterization that
our aim to work at different stages in
your and your protein product
development our software presents the
results in an electropherogram form as
well as tabular so we have peak tables
and well tables were output for all of
your data outcomes and then there's also
virtual gel formats for your for your
data presentation so this slide
describes a product bio therapeutic
product pipeline and there's different
stages so you can have targeted
discovery clone selection cell culture
optimization process development scale
up and then formulation and safety and
manufacturing and QC and we really want
and develop assays such that we're very
useful and provide quality at each step
along along the way of this process and
so if you look at the target
discovery and Crone selection we have an
angle I can test a screening and
profiling assay that can be used to look
at the glycan structures of your
products if you moving to cell culture
optimization we have the Pico protein
assay which is a covalent assay where we
label proteins and is our most sensitive
a same but we also have a low molecular
weight protein assay where the assay is
optimized to look at low molecular
weight proteins and we do quantitation
sizing and percent purity and then
protein express assay which is our
standard and one of our strongest assays
riches can analyze proteins from 14 kilo
daltons
to 200 kilo daltons and those
quantitation sizing and percent purity
in process development you may we have a
charge variant SN and then now our
newest assay is for a bioprocess
scale-up and then extending into the QC
environment and that's the new protein
clear HR asset and this can be used for
formulation stability and QC and
manufacturing and by using our
intelligent X we're able to really
obtain a high precision and inter run a
low CV values so that the protein assay
can be transferred across sites and the
user can be confident and they're sizing
and percent purity analysis from run for
run and then as you go into
manufacturing and QC you there may be
combinations thereof so there's the new
protein clear HRSA which is really
optimized for maps and the QC
environment and also development
environment where percent purity and low
low CVS and the highest precision is
needed and traceability back to a
standard if your need low molecular
weight analysis there is the low
molecular weight assay or perhaps
protein expressed si may work for you so
in total RFA's the takeaway there is
that we have several
many assays that can be that are
tailor-made for different applications
and to fit into each stage of your
process so we have one more slide that
detail some of the properties for each
of the athletes and a bit more detail
and show them side by side so as I said
the protein express was our base protein
assay and it's used for quantitation
sizing and percent purity and is from 14
kilo daltons to 200 kilo daltons and as
our highest throughput assay so you can
from from loading and injecting the
sample at the detection the run is only
42 seconds per well we also have a say
that's the low molecular weight protein
where it's similar to the protein
expressed but it's optimized for
proteins that are five to eighty kill
adults and it takes slightly longer per
well which is 60 seconds per well but
this is to achieve some resolution at
the lower molecular weight proteins and
each of all of our these chip types are
reusable for up to 400 samples now our
new protein clear assay is the the
newest of our in our protein portfolio
and this is really for formulation
stability and QC and manufacturing needs
it has an increased resolution via a
longer separation channel
it also has increased sensitivity and
better detection for low-level
impurities so we achieved this by a
optimization of the dye that we use on
board in the chip so we have better TVs
around the lower impurity levels and
then the reproducibility we achieve
better reproducibility and repeatability
by using the intelligent features that
on a Bob described with the longer
separation channel is at sixty five
seconds per well so it's still even
though a bit longer than protein Express
it's still very high throughput and
especially faster when compared to
traditional CESD SMS and on the right
side is a summary of the the other
products I described in our portfolio so
the Pico protein was the covalent
labeling assay I mentioned so
we take time upfront to actually label
the proteins prior to load it prior to
separating them on the chip and the main
advantage you get out of the Pico
protein is this has our highest
sensitivity so if you need even higher
sensitivity than the person express the
protein clear you may use the Pico
protein which would rival that silver
staining sensitivity although I'll
mention that the protein clear is quite
sensitive and that it is a LIF detection
and will go down to five nanograms per
microliter and then we have our glycan
profiling and screening which can screen
for n glycan and our charge
heterogeneity assay that works with a TI
range from seven to nine point five and
can be used to study the charge of your
proteins so now talk a bit more about
our the newest member of the protein
portfolio the protein clear assay and
the main message is that the protein
clear HRSA offers the enhanced
sensitivity resolution and
reproducibility for impurity detection
and visualization it's mainly used or
developed to be used in process
development for safety and preclinical
and the manufacturing and QC and it can
be used for the characterization
formulation stability testing and
manufacturing and quality control the
high resolution protein purity
assessment enables the detection and
visualization of impurities for
monoclonal antibody samples so it's
really designed for formats and it uses
the and it allows you to obtain
confidence in sizing and percent purity
with a high degree of intra and Inter
run reproducibility by using the
intelligent technology so for some of
those specifications the percent purity
reproducibility for the non reduced IgG
main peak is now less than 0.5 percent
and it's less than 5 percent for all of
the other impurity Peaks for sizing
in relative migration time we report a
RSD of less than 2% and we have a very
high sensitivity with a lower limit of
detection to LOD of five nanograms per
microliter for our dynamic labeling and
LIF detection and the end result is
really having confidence in the
reproducibility of the results so how do
we achieve this improved reproducibility
so we use the intelligent as the
optimization technology and this
automates the SI calibration and
optimization and as a debauch said it
really is designed to mitigate the chip
the chip and user sample preparation of
monitoring and it optimizes the voltage
and destain ratios through the
instrument and chip feedback and the
very mad reference standard so for the
destain process what's happening is that
as the analytes proceed through the SI
separation channel we apply electric
current and world channels 2 & 9 to
basically
electrically dilute the SDS
concentration to below the critical
micelle concentration and this
eliminates the background fluorescence
as Auto Bob describes and we have a
publication and analytical chemistry
that describes this if you're interested
to learn more about the fundamental
research behind this but with the
destaining process the protein about my
cells remain intact and we're able to
detect the proteins with the lower
fluorescence value it's automatically so
how do we automatically adjust the
separation voltage and peace and
currents in real-time so what we do is
we we run a very matte sample so the
very map is an IgG reference standard so
we chose IgG s for pharma customers that
are developing mad
so each standard is a map and there's
two Maps makes it a precise of ratio of
nine to one so we know the percent
purity of the map and we also know from
our
the migration time and expected
molecular weights of our ladder Peaks so
by sipping these Peaks at the very last
sample with several and sampling several
different destaining currents or
destaining conditions
we're then able to make the calibration
curve and identify the destain ratio
that will report percent purity to match
the reference standard so if your
company has a research group or
development group at site a and then at
site B or across the world if they use
the very map sample with the your
standards you should expect
reproducibility and repeatability of
your of your results and the overall
microfluidic separation is much smarter
and has a built-in calibration and
optimization so it enables the optimal
run performance for the inter as well as
integral reproducibility in the percent
purity and the molecular rate sizing so
how does the assay work when you when
you bring the protein clear HRSA entered
the laboratory and perhaps some of the
listeners are our protein Express users
so it starts with it will take the
reagent kit out of the fridge and you'll
warm the reagents up for 30 minutes we
do this to bring the dyes the room
temperature as well as the other
reagents but the diets and DMS Co so we
need to make sure this is God and
completely mixed and that's very
important for for our technology and
then you can proceed to prepare your
sample plate and your chip so you
prepare your gel and mix it with the dye
and then load this onto the caddy and
then you prepare your chip and during
this time you prepare the very map IgG
standard so this is e standard we run it
in the non-reducing condition and so we
denature and then run this as a sample
and then you can place the chip in the
instrument with your plate with your
very matte sample and then we calibrate
on the very lab sample
and then during this calibration time
it's a one-hour procedure or process
where the latter is zipped and the very
map of percent purity standard is zipped
using multiple distinct conditions and
we identify the electrical conditions so
the voltage and the destaining current
such that the latter Peaks arrive at the
set of standard arrival time and also
the destaining is set such as the
percent purity of the destaining
condition is normalized to the very map
standard now during this calibration
time you are able to process and
denature and make your other samples or
you can run it where you make very map
in your samples at the same time and
then insert it into the chip into the
instrument and press start the script
will run up to multiple times in order
to obtain a set of parameters provide
the best performance and reproducibility
and in the case where there may be a
user err where it does not calibrate or
there was a mistake in pipetting and
it's not able to calibrate the
instrument will record a warning message
to the user that the optimised
conditions were not achieved and then
one can one can start over and Intel
abrade the instrument one thing about
the protein clear assay is that the
calibration protocol must be run prior
to the sample run as that is really how
it's designed to meet the specifications
for the intra and the inter run
classification so to show a bit more
data about the reproducibility so shown
here are some CD values for different
samples so IgG non reduced main peak
reduced heavy chain on non glycosylated
heavy chain and the reduced heavy chain
so we see in Tehran and in Tehran TVs so
for each of these
should these Peaks that you see data for
they were sipped and we made a master
plate and they were each sample would
sip 24 times during a run and the run
was we did nine different runs and
across those nine different runs we had
three different users of five different
chips and five different instruments so
it's quite a quite diverse set therefore
for varying the conditions to challenge
ourselves and you can see if our sizing
and our percent purity CDs so for the
intro run our sizing specification is 2%
and we're coming in about 0.4 to 0.5
percent and similarly in trove run for
the percent purity we want to be less
than 0.5% for the main non reduce IgG
and you can see that were safely clear
of that as 0.1 4% and our other Peaks
are also within our 5% specification
what we're really excited about the
inter run TV and which we're also able
to decrease that per to lower those two
very very good CV values so similarly
our sizing is less than to 2% as well as
our percent purity specifications which
are less than 0.5% and 5% for the male
peak when the impurity Peaks
respectively we have a resolution specs
are shown here on this slide is for the
very mad where we're setting it to a
value indicating that our percent purity
standard that each of those Peaks our
baseline resolved so that when you use
that standard even though they're both
mad their baseline result such that we
have a good calibration for the percent
purity and a linear concentration range
from 10 to 1000 nanograms per microliter
the LOD of these assing is 5 nanogram
per microliter and the linearity is is
very strong so greater than 0.995 and
shown here is the zoom in of the of
non-readers tea
and you can really see the impurity
detection of the protein clear assay so
you can see a clip and you can see some
of the different different impurity
heavy heavy light and some of the other
impurity Peaks that are important for
the researcher to identify in the bio
therapeutic environment so with that the
protein clear assay is really designed
to provide high resolution protein
purity assessment and enable the
detection and visualization of
impurities within a map sample it's
developed for maximum precision because
we're incising and percent purity and we
do this with the intelligent and the
very map percent purity reference
standard and calibrating each assay and
adjusting the electrical conditions to
normalize against the standard and then
also is able to have enough resolution
compared to the protein expressed as a
enabling you to have better
characterization of impurities the
intelligent as the optimization is novel
and it offers the real-time si
calibration and the very map IgG
restaurant standard provides a reference
calibration and also provides
traceability for your characterization
so with that I would like to thank our
audience very much and uh nabob and I
welcome any questions excellent
presentations dr. Tripathi and dr. white
thanks for bringing that information to
us so before we get started with all of
your questions here's a quick reminder
about how to reach us today questions
can be sent via the green Q&A button the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll get to as many as we can our first
question is
dr. white this first question is for you
are there any common troubleshooting
issues that a user should be aware of
yes from our experience we know that
there's there are several things as a
troubleshooting that can be performed to
give the optimal SAT performance one is
kind of up front is that we emphasize
with customers to have really good
pipetting technique especially when it's
going across sites this can make a
difference and using the reverse
pipetting for the viscous gel mixtures
cleanliness of the instrument is is
quite important making sure to clean it
and purge the instrument line so there's
a purge function on the instrument so
our R&D group does this really routinely
and pays a lot of attention to this
because we are applying that the
currents and voltages to tune the D
stained channels and so if if
cleanliness falls off and currently
start then we have to troubleshoot and
get the instrument that's the working
order but really with good cleanliness
and good pipetting technique should be
in good shape we know one of the
important steps also is the thawing and
preparing the mixture of the gel dye
mixture this is important such that the
dye ratio and concentration is delivered
properly on ship and so we know it's
important to really slow down and adhere
to the mixing procedure that's outlined
in our and our user guide where you
invert the to multiple times and
vortexes for the full time if if that
step is done hastily one may result in
dips or miss labeling and then that
really just comes back to improper gel
formulation so if we pay attention to
the cleanliness of the instrument the
purging the critical step of formation
of the gel dye that gets the instrument
set up and then for protein clear if one
observes the little artifact in the
baseline while we don't during our
validation and our
be we don't take any steps during our
test procedures and we don't see that
often in our hand if one does see those
that's very important we know for the QC
customer because the instrument is quite
high throughput one can run PBS blanks
and kind of recondition the chip and
then and then collect additional samples
so those are some of the common things
that have come up and could be helpful
for customers to them next one is for
dr. Tripathi how does it stand up
against something like the Beckman pa
800 yeah that's a good question I think
what we observe doing the experiments
involved instruments that first the time
it takes in Beckman 800 both for the
preparing for Beckman experiments as
well as time to take si is quite long so
it's about 10 minutes and and some time
many many minutes before preparation
time in terms of using this latch if he
extra preparation time is very very
small because this instrument
procurements Truman basically pushes the
gel loads Lords everything and get the
job ready and quite amazingly the assay
as we shown in the results in in this
webinar we take only sixty to 140
seconds to finish the experiments
typically around sixty seconds do that
that's a quite a big woman the other
technical part is is the baseline and as
when we did NIST map we found that the
results were quite a baseline was quite
wavy for p800
where we are we found actually gf touch
was quite stable and that's important
because determination of percentage
purity actually is some time baseline
resolution the other thing is that we
want to emphasize is that that the mist
mAb was very standard and we knew what
is the percentage purity and both p800
and the touch got same data reproducible
and the border border instrument so but
the key factor is the DX touch got the
same data participant data as be eternal
but much much shorter time it's about
thirty or thirty sixty Seconds so that I
could highlight is is a key advantages
of a lab chip yet it's one more very
important I don't know about p800 inside
algorithm and all that but we do know as
as we are presenting in webinar but lab
subjected touch system actually taking
care of small errors and with this
intelligent technology so those errors
have to come in the cage and the user in
different places in the world and this
is forward-looking it's like going you
know five ten years from now these as is
will become popular we're just don't
take care of of the errors coming to
unknown hackers and that is anybody's
mind about it doctor right next one is
for you in what format it's data
exported from the instrument and is
designed for QC laboratories yes so
electropherograms that he grams the gel
images as well as the peak tables and
well tables and the pig tables and well
table is containing information on your
sizing percent purity concentration
height all those important outcomes may
be exported they are analyzed in the the
reviewers lab ship reviewer software
they can be exported in a CSV file you
can take those to excel or you can also
take those to as AI a file that's
important especially with design for for
QC customers because if your laboratory
uses in power or chameleon that data
format may be used on those
forms and you can process the raw data
for the QC Laboratories we also have a
GXP patch that you can put on the
software and basically what this does is
it allows the laboratory to set up
control over user access and and gives
different user passwords and controls
what they're allowed to adjust on the
instrument so once your method is locked
and you have an operator that will be
doing QC they'll be able to log in and
only run the assay so with those things
in mind that's how it was designed for
the data export for the process
development and their QC laboratory next
one is for dr. chapathi do your Alice's
have a letter with a high molecular
weight peak to bracket on a clonal
antibodies can you repeat please yes do
your assays have a ladder with a high
molecular weight peak to bracket
monoclonal antibodies yes indeed we have
actually the latter actually this assay
is designed to to bracket most of the
antibodies investigated by biophysics
scientific community so yes it is F is
taken care of that in fact it's
optimizing around that map which is
called very map standard which is
designed around those available or
antibodies and you can add if I can just
add to that so the protein clear assay
has a ladder peak at 250 killer Dalton's
and that peak was introduced to bracket
a normal map molecular weight around 150
so that is a feature of our newer the
newest protein clear assay well if there
are no more questions I would like to
once again thank dr. chapathi and dr.
white for their presentations do you
have any final comments no we'd just
like to thank everyone for
listening to the webinar we're very
excited about the the new technology and
to continue the Rd at PerkinElmer and we
appreciate all of the questions and as
more come in through the on-demand
features we look forward to answering
those and getting back to you yeah thank
you everybody thank you and I would also
like to thank our sponsor PerkinElmer
for making it possible to bring this
presentation to you this webinar has
been approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CC button at
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through April of 2018 you'll
receive an email from us alerting you
when it's available on demand and posted
on lab routes calm you're welcome to
Ford this announcement to any colleagues
who weren't able to join in today thanks
for logging on and participating in
today's broadcast we will see you next
time